[Música]
en Bruselas la bandera finlandesa ya
ondea junto a las insignias de los otros
30 países de la organización del tratado
del Atlántico Norte Finlandia ya es
miembro de pleno derecho de la otan con
un proceso que empezó a raíz de la
invasión rusa de Ucrania helsinki Deja
atrás su no alineamiento militar
Moscú guía deploró la ampliación de la
alianza
Estados Unidos a la espera de la
histórica comparecencia ante la justicia
de Donald Trump por el caso Story
Daniels el primer expresidente en
enfrentar cargos penales ya se encuentra
en Manhattan para su cita en la corte
china advierte al presidente de la
cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos que no se reúna mañana con la
presidenta de Taiwán a riesgo de
aumentar la tensión entre ambos países
además Beijing condenó que filipinas
haya ofrecido a Washington abrir cuatro
bases militares en el archipiélago
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
masdeo y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
Bruselas porque culminó allí el proceso
de adhesión de Finlandia a la otan
recordemos que la integración más rápida
de la historia reciente de la
organización empezó a raíz de la
invasión rusa de Ucrania cuando
Finlandia que comparte
1.300 kilómetros de frontera con Rusia
decidió dejar atrás décadas de no
alineamiento militar el kremlin ya ha
declarado que responderá a esta
ampliación de la otan pero que la
situación de Finlandia no puede
compararse con la de Ucrania repasemos
ahora la expansión de la organización
del tratado del Atlántico Norte desde su
fundación como Alianza defensiva en 1949
este martes Finlandia se convirtió en
miembro de la organización para el
tratado del Atlántico Norte otan debido
a la guerra en Ucrania puso fin a
décadas de no alineamiento militar
la otan fue creada el 4 de abril de 1949
como una alianza de defensa colectiva en
su nacimiento estuvo formada por doce
países que coincidían en ver a la unión
soviética como una amenaza después
entraron Grecia Turquía Alemania y
España y en 1999 llegarían los primeros
satélites de la ya extinta Unión
soviética Hungría Polonia República
Checa en 2004 accedieron siete países
donde destacaban aliados soviéticos del
Pacto de Varsovia y las ex repúblicas
soviéticas bálticas como letonia
lituania y Estonia fronterizas con Rusia
la ampliación terminó con las anexiones
de Croacia y Albania en 2009 la de
Montenegro en 2017 y la de macedonia del
Norte en 2020 y ahora Finlandia en 2023
31 países en total el kremlin reaccionó
a la llegada de Finlandia y dice que su
adhesión supone un riesgo para la región
la otan está tomando una serie de
medidas para aumentar la preparación
para el combate de las armadas conjuntas
están intensificando el entrenamiento de
combate y las actividades de
reconocimiento cerca de las fronteras de
Rusia y velarús por supuesto todo esto
crea riesgos de una escalada
significativa del conflicto Vladimir
Putin ha acusado a la otan de violar su
supuesta Promesa de no expandirse más
allá de sus fronteras de 1990 Rusia
exige que el bloque occidental adquiera
compromisos en materia de seguridad
rechazando una eventual integración de
Ucrania a la alianza militar y el retiro
de la infraestructura militar instalada
en Europa del este después de 1997
Suecia sigue a la espera de la
aprobación por parte de Turquía para
convertirse en el siguiente miembro de
la alianza
vamos ahora a Nueva York porque con
manifestaciones de apoyo y de rechazo
Estados Unidos está a la espera de la
comparecencia histórica de Donald Trump
ante la justicia a raíz de su imputación
en el caso stormy Daniels recordemos que
este proceso que implica el mal uso de
fondos de campaña en el pago por el
silencio de una actriz porno ha
convertido a Trump en el primer ex
presidente que enfrenta cargos penales a
esta hora se registran manifestaciones
en la gran manzana a favor y en contra
del ex mandatario analizamos ahora el
futuro del expresidente con Heidi Jane
Smith analista política y doctora por la
Florida International University Heidi
Buenos días para usted le pregunto si
este caso penal perjudica a Trump o si
toda esta atención mediática lo
beneficia en términos de su
precandidatura a las presidenciales de
Sí muchas gracias muchas gracias por la
invitación lo que estamos viendo Es el
estado de derecho en los Estados Unidos
que está la fiscal debiendo la del
presidente Trump Por lo cual significa
que Donald Trump ha tenido mucho la
palabra en las últimas semanas sobre hoy
en día pero donde estamos hoy en días
que el fiscal está presentando el caso
de las diferentes situaciones que tiene
Por lo cual son sí Perdone continúe que
ha habido un error en la en la conexión
Sí hay tres hay otros hay otros juicios
que estén en adelante uno de por el
estado de Georgia que fue una cuestión
de votación mucho más grave y otra para
la Federal
que tiene unos casos mucho más
importantes entonces hoy en día es es
una situación de pago por medio de una
estrella de porno como bien han dicho y
la verdad es que es la primera vez que
tenemos una expresidente en
en esa situación ahora el estado derecho
es donde presenta y es para verse Cómo
se afecta lo que hemos visto en el
sentido de los republicanos es que están
también viendo Cuál es el motivo el
dicho y cómo está moviendo los medios y
los mediáticos por parte de Trump no
hemos escuchado de Trump pero los
últimos meses salvo esos casos de
de juicio ante los televisores Y
entonces él aprovecho mucho estos
momentos para su candidaturas políticas
también los partidos demócratas están
también esperando en verse Cómo va a
salir de la situación tanto de
cuestiones de mediáticos como como
y Heidi precisamente tranvía ha
anunciado que esta noche se quiere
dirigir a sus seguidores desde su
residencia de mar a lago como usted lo
decía aprovechando no esta situación
para hacerle de alta voz pero por otro
lado también veíamos ante esta
comparecencia manifestaciones en contra
del expresidente con pancartas diciendo
los juicios contra Trump solo acaban de
empezar Cómo puede afectar este proceso
en particular a la polarización de la
sociedad estadounidense
pues lo que vemos es que hay una
silladores muy dirigidos a la
candidatura de los fondos de base para
para seguir el ex presidente Trump lo
cual es normal que fue precedente por
cuatro años lo que también hemos visto
es que tiene más jueces en contra de él
y por lo cual Apenas vamos con el
derecho al Estado para para demostrar
que que ha violado la ley y cuál
cualquier persona que vio la ley está
abajo del de de de los requisitos para
cumplir Entonces lo que estamos viendo
ahora es el estado de derecho de los
Estados Unidos
Heidi Jane Smith Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros en France 24 y por su
análisis
Muchas gracias nosotros cambiamos de
información porque en India siete
personas murieron en una avalancha de
nieve en el Himalaya cerca del paso
fronterizo hacia el Tíbet además ocho
personas se encuentran en estado crítico
según informaron las autoridades los
trabajadores de emergencias anunciaron
el rescate de 20 personas con vida
mientras reforzaron las labores de
búsqueda antes de la caída de la noche
en los últimos dos años 120 personas han
muerto por avalanchas de nieve en el
Himalaya un fenómeno acelerado por el
cambio climático según documentó la
academia de ciencias naturales de
Estados Unidos según un testigo citado
por la agencia reuters la policía local
había desaconsejado a los turistas
visitar la zona
en otras noticias las autoridades de
Beijing han advertido al presidente de
la cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos El republicano Kevin mccarthy que
no siga adelante con la reunión que
tiene prevista mañana en California con
la presidenta de Taiwán
la portavoz del Ministerio de exteriores
de China ha insistido en que el
encuentro violaría al principio de una
sola china recordemos que tras la visita
a Taiwán el agosto pasado de la entonces
presidenta de la cámara la demócrata
Nancy pelosi china lanzó una gran
maniobra de ejercicios militares en el
estrecho de Taiwán por otro lado Beijing
también condenó hoy que filipinas haya
propuesto a Washington abrir cuatro
nuevas bases militares en el
archipiélago
china se opone firmemente al arreglo del
gobierno de Estados Unidos para quetzai
transite por Estados Unidos china se
opone a la reunión entre macarthy el
tercer líder más importante del gobierno
de Estados Unidos y presidente de la
cámara de representantes con Saint in
weng porque esta acción viola gravemente
del principio de una china y los tres
comunicados conjuntos chinos
estadounidenses lo que daña gravemente
la soberanía y la integridad territorial
de China
Muchísimas gracias por su atención
enseguida volvemos
[Música]